the US Navy has released disturbing  images of two fully armed Russian  fighter jets that the Navy says flew  dangerously close to u.s. maritime  reconnaissance plan the Russian jets  flew on either side of the American  aircraft over international waters in  the eastern Mediterranean Sea yesterday  the u.s. 6th fleet says the intercept  lasted a little more than an hour the  Navy says this is the third time in two  months Russian pilots have done  something like this Tony the Russian  Jets are su-35s or supersonic jets the  p8 aircraft the reconnaissance plane is  a modified 737 so not really a fair game  of chicken there now look the big Top  Gun reboot who got pushed off because of  the coronavirus we don't need Top Gun  going on for real on the skies above  because a small miscalculation could  lead to some really bad outcomes  so that's frightening stuff there